my life as a mic level good thanks so
much for sticking around till the last
afternoon of the conference it's really
good to be here I was one of the the
attendees and speakers at the original
PI data back at Google in 2012 and been
really fun to see that the conference
series grow over this time and also to
see the community grow as well it's
great to be here so I want to talk to
you about a new project that Jake Vander
PLAs and I have been working on for just
under a year now we just released the
Wando release of altair back at Syfy in
early July we're really excited about
this project and I'll just dive right in
so want to talk about take a step back
first and talk about visualization and
python and if you've done anything with
visualization and python at this point
you're probably sitting there thinking
the following right now oh no please not
another visualization library in Python
I already used matplotlib and when that
doesn't work I have to jump out to
Seaborn and when I want to interactivity
I use plotly or bouquet or BQ plot and
sometimes I get sick of all of it and I
just go over to our and use ggplot2 I
don't need something else to keep track
of right why sort of what's behind the
current situation so there's many
powerful libraries for visualization in
Python map pot lid the ones I've
mentioned here each of these libraries
does certain things very well and
ultimately just about any visualization
is possible in Python and even there's
some bright points in the the API design
of these libraries and the abstractions
a lot of them are inspired by or modeled
on welcome
since grammar of graphics however
there's also a lot of pain visualization
is a persistent and significant source
of user pain I see this a lot when I'm
teaching we see it a lot in our work
with project on project Jupiter because
Jupiter 10 is the user interface for all
of these tools users tend to complain to
us about all of the tools so they'll be
using Jupiter and complain to us about
scikit-learn or about matplotlib
visualization is one of the top things
where we're hearing from people this
first quote is actually me I've been
using that pot lived for about a decade
and I still have to look most things up
or you might hear people say I love
Python but I fire up our studio to do
visualizations and ggplot2
why is that there's a sparse handling of
statistical visualization I'll talk more
about exactly what I mean by that
categorical data date time data and
users have to write code even for
incidental aspects of visualizations new
and experienced users have to track and
learn all these different libraries and
make decisions about what library to use
for a given task and many of the very
basic things are still horribly
complicated here's a simple example so
some time when you get home fire up the
Jupiter notebook and import matplotlib
grab a data frame of your choice make a
2-d scatterplot of the tuple of two
quantitative columns they're probably
just gonna do matplotlib dot scatter now
facet your scatter plot or trellis your
scatter plot by categorical column you
might dig into like pandas built in
plotting you might go over to Seabourn
and see if it has something along those
lines you may actually pandas hair
Seabourn has a low-level API for
faceting you might start to look at now
try faceted histograms and you may think
well gosh pandas worked great for
faceted
scatterplots but oh my gosh I used to
not handle faceted histograms maybe they
fixed up now I don't know I can't keep
track of it and now color the points are
bar by the hour of a date/time calling
and you're gonna realize oh gosh
matplotlib date/time handling isn't that
great panda says date/time column rocks
but Seabourn i'm not sure actually
now try teaching all this to someone
who's learning data science with python
or try convincing an hour user that
python is really awesome and that they
should use it so what do i mean by
statistical visualization there are many
different types of visualizations in
statistical visualization is a very
small subset of the overall types of
visualizations that could be performed
and here's my might the simple concise
way of thinking about that first the
data to be visualized is in a data frame
so it's a tabular format sort of like a
spreadsheet and the data frame is in a
tidy format the tidy format is something
that had the Wickham sort of introduced
the language about a very short summary
of that the columns are observed
variables of a given data type to be
quantitative categorical date/time and
then the rows are samples from some
observation and typically the data is
mapped to visual properties using a
group by operation and you'll see more
of how this emerges it it's not obvious
when you start doing visualization that
there's a group by going on underneath
but this is I think what are the key
properties of statistical visualization
and the reason where one of the reasons
I and others refer to it as statistical
visualization is that the groups in the
group by operation in this context with
a tidy data frame correspond to
conditional probability distributions
visualization grammar statistical
visualizations can be expressed with a
small number of abstractions that form a
visualization
grammar my training is physics and in
physics we we really like very simple
models that have a small number of
abstractions that you can reuse in
different ways right so for example a
great example is F equals MA
it is Newton's laws once you know the
force on a mass and you know its mass
you can solve that differential equation
and find the acceleration what's
fantastic is it's a very simple model
but it applies to a good fraction of our
universe so it's a few abstractions that
can be applied across to ride range of
situations a visualization grammar is
similar to that so there's sort of
different layers in a visualization
grammar first is the data and this is
really the input data that would be in
the tidy format that I referred to next
is that the data is typically
transformed
there's grouping aggregation summary
statistics projection and layout
typically in Python we think of
transformation as being something that
you do before visualization and I think
one of the the big revelations that I
had is that when you're doing a
statistical visualization it's really
difficult to do all the transformation
before the visualization is done you
really need to build any data
transformation pipeline into the
visualization process itself next is
scales scales map data values to visual
properties the way I think of scales is
that there's sort of three basic data
types quantitative date/time and
categorical and then there's visual
properties color shape facet row you
know the position in a row faster dark
column facet and you need a way of
mapping from all those data types to all
of those visual properties so there's
maybe n data types and M visual
properties you can think of needing a
total of n times M scales that know how
to map across those different things to
perform all the visualizations that you
might want to perform if you want to
think of sort of where the existing
tools and Python week it's this is one
area tools like matplotlib tend to be
really good and have scales that can map
from quantitative columns to properties
like X&Y position and color but when you
get into categoricals and date times
mapping to shapes or other things like
that
they're quite weak or have no story
whatsoever
next is guides so guides are things like
axes and legends that enable you to
visualize a scale and then finally
there's going to be marks some sort of
shape or mark that represents the data
on the visualization declarative api's
so this is something that we've been
doing with project Jupiter for a long
time now
both the notebook format and our message
spec that the front end uses to talk to
curls our declarative and so it's
something we've been doing although we
have honestly in Jupiter I think the
power of that is sort of beneath the
surface a little more than it is here in
the visualization space so what do I
mean by declarative versus versus an
imperative API the first specifies what
should be done imperative specifies how
it should be done
declarative you have the how is an
internal detail that the user never
really worries about all they say is get
this done and I don't care how it gets
done in an imperative approach you have
to provide detailed logics for all the
individual steps along the way
declarative separate specification from
execution whereas imperative there's
sort of a sensitive dependence on
initial conditions with imperative API
is that if the what changes the steps
may change completely and that's really
difficult and painful from the user
perspective
so why declarative API first is
usability the what question is usually
closer to the users end goal than the
how question honestly most users when
there
working with data would love it if it
were entirely magic right if it would
like read your mind and then magically
do all the pre-processing and the
transformations and the visualizations
and the machine learning like that would
be fantastic if it just magically read
our minds in the thing that would it
would have to read about our mind is the
what what are we trying to do what
questions are we trying to ask that's
usually closer to a declaratory of API
users have to write less code and
there's fewer abstractions so there's
lower cognitive load leaving more of
your brain power for thinking about the
actual important questions but there's a
lot of other side benefits that are
really fun one is that there's a natural
serialization format such as JSON for
sharing and portability it's also
possible to auto-generate api's code
examples and tests we'll talk more about
that it's much easier to support
multiple languages the visualization
tools today that do support multiple
languages are typically built on top of
declarative API underneath and then
performance with an imperative API it's
really easy for the user to make things
slow well it's easy for them to make
things slow hard for them to make things
fast they have to be responsible for
that
with a declarative approach the
implementer can be responsible for
performance obviously that places places
a larger burden on the implementer but
that's the idea right that the user has
less burden so given this background how
do we map out the current space of
visualization tools so here's a little I
guess it's a pictorial chart with
imperative versus declarative or
declarative on
and even use and versus powerful I'm not
really happy with these labels
ease-of-use and powerful being the
labels I'm not quite sure what to call
it though I think it's probably more of
a continuous scale than a categorical
where one is sort of how high level
versus low level it's ease of use is one
aspect powerful is another aspect in the
lower corner is matt partland matt
partland is extremely powerful
you can basically get matplotlib to draw
anything you would want but it's pretty
much imperative one of my favorite
tweets about alt era has been someone
who saw this and said actually this is
why I use map let live write notice it's
the only tool down in that left corner
that's extremely powerful and imperative
right
Seabourn much less general so it's not
quite as powerful still imperative but
it's easier to use for a lot of things
right if Seabourn happens to have a
chart that is the chart that you want
it's awesome
it's really nice down here decorative
sorry declarative but powerful there's
tools like d3.js Vega bouquet plot Lee
in BQ plot it may not be completely
obvious to you that these are
declarative but for the most part they
are not entirely and then up in the
upper right here for declarative and
sort of high-level easy to use
statistical graphics there's ggplot2
Vega light and bouquet charts some of
these tools like d3 is a great example I
would say is not purely declarative
there are aspects where you have to
provide callback functions that actually
implement sort of take steps along the
way so the Altair is built on top of a
JavaScript stack the lowest layer and
the stack is d3 GS again it's a
declarative mostly declarative it's a
JavaScript library it's extreme
be powerful but also very verbose so for
example to produce a simple bar chart
like this here's the the code that's
required for that and because of that
for a lot of sort of working data
scientists d3 is a bit painful it tends
to be sort of highly optimized for sort
of custom highly customized to bespoke
graphics that the type that you see in
new york times the next layer up is Vega
Vega is basically a declarative JSON
layer on top of d3 what do I mean by
that the Vega J's or JavaScript library
takes in a JSON data structure that
describes the visualization an example
is shown on the left here compiles that
down into d3 and so the visualization is
still done in d3 but the input for that
is not JavaScript code but is that the
JSON data structure it's again very
powerful but also still very verbose
it's actually very comparable to the
sort of role of layers of bouquet and
plotly not not identical but a lot of
the same same abstractions are there
there's also similarities there to be q
plot and then on top of that is Vega
light so Vega light again is a JSON spec
it's a declarative approach for visuals
specifying a visualization the Vega
light javascript library compiles that
JSON down to Vega which then gets
compiled down to d3 for for rendering so
there's sort of a stack of tools here
and you can see here the JSON data
required for a simple bar chart is all
of a sudden much simpler than it was for
Vega obviously each step that you move
up this stack
you're losing power there's fewer things
that you can do the sort of the scope of
the visualization tool gets reduced Vega
light
is strictly focused on statistical
visualization in the sense that I talked
about before where as Vega and d3 get
increasingly more powerful and can
handle more arbitrary types of
visualizations big alight from sort of
capabilities perspective is probably
closest to ggplot2 in terms of
conceptually what else am I missing here
I think that that's good so I want to
talk and introduce you to Altair so I'll
tear is a Python API for declarative
statistical visualizations it performs
no actual rendering of visualizations
you may say well that's really weird to
have a visualization library that
doesn't actually visualize anything it
actually it's just a rendering part
though that it doesn't perform what it
does is emit type checked invalidate in
Vega like JSON which we then hand over
to Vega light for compilation into Vega
for rendering is d3 so all altair does
is has a Python API that at the end of
the day emits this JSON blob that the
other javascript libraries consume and
render the advantage of this approach is
that there's an opportunity for these
other visualization libraries in python
matplotlib ok plotly to add their own
Vega light renders right there's a
reason people use matplotlib or there's
a reason people use bouquet for example
if you want absolutely perfect
publication ready PDFs vector drawn
matplotlib is still the tool of choice
right what we're trying to do is
advocate Vega light as sort of a common
data exchange format for high level
statistical visualizations so for
example we're talking with the map pot
live and the bouquet and the poly
developers and trying to convince them
to implement Vega light renders so that
you could use the API that Altair offers
or just write the Vega light JSON
yourself and then pick which of those
renders
want to use any giving context if you
want the full fancy interactive
web-based options that something like
plotly or bouquet offers you could use
those renders if you want what Matt plot
lib has to offer you could use that for
a render and in a sense we're Vega light
then becomes a lingua franca of data
visualization so here's a simple Altair
example right now the the default render
that we have is works in a Jupiter
notebook so if you run altair in the
jupiter notebook it just magically works
and it's using the JavaScript libraries
for d3 Vega and Vega light you can see
the declarative nature of this the
there's a data set here that's a data
frame I pick a mark type using mark
circle and then I encode the data with
visual property so here the X visual
property is going to use the horsepower
column the Y property is going to use
the miles per gallon and that the color
is going to be the origin column and
everything is done from there up so you
don't have to say I want this particular
color map I want a legend drawn with
this and this is one of the advantages
is that with a declarative approach and
with a constrained model of
visualization we can make all those
choices for you now obviously you can
come along and do some customization
that is possible but in in many cases
when you're doing exploratory
visualization you don't want to mess
with that you just want to see see a
visualization and say to yourself know
the the correlation that I was expecting
is not here or oh wow there's a
different thing going on here than I
thought so what would this looked like
in matplotlib this same plot and here I
want to show you how a group by
operation is sitting underneath Vega
light in this type of model so notice I
have a function here scatter that makes
a single
gotta plot for a group a particular
subset of rows in the data set and then
in pandas I do group by the origin which
is a categorical column and then I want
to apply that scatter function to each
of those groups right so basically if
you want to think of unpacking this as a
loop you would say for a group in groups
make a scatter plot of that group
picking a particular color that you want
to use for that for that group notice
though so you have to do the group by by
hand in matplotlib and you also have to
do things like the legend and the axes
labels by hand in that plot lip as well
this is a really simple example it's not
too bad to do this in matplotlib some of
the more complex things that Altair and
Vega light can do would be quite a
nightmare in matplotlib so Altair is
robust why do I say that most of the
Altair codebase is auto-generated from
the Vega light JSON specification so I
don't know the exact fraction but
basically our Altair codebase consists
of a JSON file that just comes from the
Vega light repository that specifies
what the json data structures could look
like we read that JSON file and then we
have a bunch of ginger templates that we
you'd use to auto-generate the Python
API that we have this ensures that we're
pretty much guaranteed that as long as
that JSON file is an accurate
representation of Vega light that we
follow that exactly this applies to our
API to our entire test suite and even
things like our example notebooks we are
performing type checking and validation
of the Vega light that's generated using
trait 'lets and we're not quite so we're
not mathematicians so we're not going to
make sort of a guarantee of mathematical
certainty but basically you'll get more
or less guaranteed that the JSON
produced by Altair is going to be valid
big alight it may not produce the
visualization
you want but it's not going to cause
everything to explode so Altair is also
usable we have carefully designed this
API focused on usability it's something
that Jake and I have spent a lot of time
with so for example all the attributes
it's mostly an attribute based API all
the attributes on setting are type
checked there's a thin layer of
convenience methods the Vega light spec
is rather nested and for from a
programmatic perspective highly nested
api's are difficult and so we we flatten
that API slightly using some convenience
methods and we're really happy with how
that turned out
and then in a few careful places we
allow things like method chaining and
we've overridden operators such as plus
and plus equals for layering there's
intelligent heuristics such as type
inference right you've got a panda's
data frame pandas knows what the types
of your columns are in a vanillite
specification you have to specify your
data types we can do that automatically
because we have the original data I can
do that inference there's also a
shorthand notation for specifying
columns data types and aggregation and
then there's extensive documentation and
over 70 examples and Altera also and
Vega light come with a large number of
data sets similar to two ggplot2 and so
we also ship those as well Altair is
powerful in the Jupiter notebook Altair
can produce canvas SVG or PNG s all the
visualizations in the Jupiter notebook
will also show up in your notebooks when
they're rendered on github or in B
viewer and you'll see here in some of
the demos there's a button to just click
in the notebook to download as PNG or
open the visualization in the online
vega light editor it's easy to serialize
these visualizations as json that's
their sort of native format and then i I
don't have an example of this but
you can actually if you find a Vega
light visualization on the internet
somewhere as JSON you can copy that into
Jupiter notebook and Altair can generate
the Python code that would generate that
spec and you can start to play with it
in Python again an advantage of the the
declarative nature of Vega like doing
things like that is I mean we had to
write some code but it wasn't
particularly difficult to do that type
of thing so if you want to explore and
try out Altera for yourself there's a
Conda package for the PIP package one
additional step is needed to enable the
JavaScript extension if you pip install
this Conda does is able to do that
automatically
I'll tell ships with example notebooks
and that you can grab just by doing from
altair import star and then calling the
tutorial function and I'm just going to
do that now and show you some demos
so I'm just gonna import everything from
altair and then call the tutorial
function so what this does is you can
see here in my desktop it has downloaded
an altair tutorial folder all of these
tutorial notebooks shipped inside the
Altair Python package so you don't have
to be on the Internet to grab that and
then we have just notebooks and then we
display a table of contents of those
notebooks here in the actual Jupiter
notebook let's see we try to get a sense
of how much time I have so I think I
want to run through some of the
introduction here
so obviously normally we all don't
recommend importing star from anything
but it's nice for simple examples like
this again
the data in an altar visualization is a
data frame so here's a very simple data
frame it's actually so here's a simple
data frame and the basic object in
altair is a chart and you instantiate a
chart by passing it the data and notice
even without anything else beyond that
it can artist for visualization now here
it's not doing any visual encoding so
the entire data set is represented as a
as a circle you can see what the the the
Vega light JSON looks like for that so
you can see this the format is really
simple there's a data key that has the
data values and then the mark type is
point next you're typically going to
want to do the visual encoding you're
gonna call the encode method big alight
and I'll tear support the following
visual properties to XY color opacity
shape size row column detail text label
path and order and so let's encode the
the Y visual property as the a column
and now you can see so again go up here
the a column is a categorical and Altair
and Vega light are smart enough to know
that a categorical style axes and
labeling should be used for that again
we can look at the the JSON data
structure for that notice now there's an
encoding field and for each visual
property there's going to be an entry
where the field is is going to name the
column in the data set the type is going
to be the underlying data type in this
case it's nominal Vega light and Altair
support two categorical types a nominal
and ordinal which represent unordered
and ordered categoricals respectively
there's also so the here's the four
basic data type
there's a shorthand single letter code
for that so if you need to override the
type inference that Altair is doing you
can use this notation the name of the
column colon and then a capital letter
specifying the type let's actually
encode both x and y position right so
here we have more or less at a
scatterplot but again these are
categoricals and so it's smart enough to
handle that I'm running short on time so
I'm gonna skip through some of this here
are the other marks that Altair and Vega
light supports area bar circle line
point rule square text and tick and
actually I'm gonna jump over and look at
some examples here in the last few
minutes so here's loading a one of the
data sets that comes with Vega light and
Altair so we can encode the horsepower
column as the exposition and then add
the Y position is mile per gallon we can
make it a bubble chart by encoding the
size as the acceleration again the the
legends added automatically or maybe we
want to encode both color and shape as
the origin column and now we have
different shapes and colored used for
the different values of the categorical
in the origin field and then the thing I
want to emphasize again is the small
number of abstractions to change the
chart dramatically I'm changing a very
small amount in the API I mean all I'm
changing is the visual encoding the
mapping between data columns and visual
properties yeah
yes so the question is about
interactivity animations and our
activity Vega so remember there's the
the layering so there's d3 Vega and Vega
light d3 and Vega obviously support lots
of rich interactions and visual
animations those are still being added
to Vega light our expectation is that
those are going to show up in Vega light
this fall and then all of that will show
up in in Altair things like selections
cross filtering zooming panning tooltips
all of that will will show up so let's
see here you can switch to a mark type
of a circle rather than a hollow point
here's a square based scatter chart mark
square a text-based scatter chart right
there's a very consistent coherent set
of scales that know how to map things
like text to one of the columns or a
tick chart it so again all you're doing
here is changing the mark type and you
get a completely different type of
visualization yeah
or
part of what is really interesting about
Vega light is that so you've got the a
couple different abstractions one you've
got your columns in your data frame
you've got the mark types and you've got
the visual properties and it's not
always obvious what happens when you
combine different combinations of those
the thing that's amazing is that they
all work like in you can think of there
being some some three-dimensional cube
of categorical date/time and quantities
visual properties on another axis and
mark types on the other and you might
imagine some of those combinations are
going to explode and they basically all
work now they may not produce a
visualization that is what you want the
only thing that I can say that that
we've done is like just start playing
around there's I can show you an example
here from the cars data set so here's
some faceting all you do to get
fascinating is row equals the name of a
column or column equals that so here's a
more complex example so X sorry Y is an
Origin X here is an aggregation that's
counting so it's sort of like a
histogram sorted descending colors is
cylinders and then we're doing a bar
chart but the stacking is a normalized
normalized approach so it's a lot going
on in something like that here's another
example of at the text mark alright
basically you end up with a colored
table right where the colors again are
mapped in this case through the means of
the the miles-per-gallon column and so
again it's not always obvious what
you're going to end up with but you can
with the small number of abstractions
produce a wide range of visualizations
one minute but you know I want to
emphasize that this is a constrained
visualization model it really is and
there's going to be a lot of
visualizations that matplotlib can do
that Seaborn can do that are outside of
the scope of this and it's important to
keep that in mind other things that it
has is for date/time columns you often
have to make decisions about what time
unit to use in your visualization right
so here there's a year column internally
that would get converted to some
date/time column and I mean for example
if you start plotting in matplotlib you
might get seconds right or something
silly like that
and so here Seabourn sorry Altair and
Vega light no allow you to specify a
time unit so you can space of a day of
week day of month month of year day of
year all those different things yes
but this yeah you you can customize all
the angles yeah you can change that yeah
there's a you so notice there's a
configure cell here there's a bunch of
configure methods and a rich
configuration system for sort of
customizing the visualization so I think
I'm gonna stop there there maybe yeah we
can have quite a little bit of Q&A
so my question was about the time series
do you guys support resampling or
aggregation two different things so for
example if I have time series data and
I'm gonna look at my daily or my yearly
or my quarterly or whatever is that part
of a config or is that a pre-processing
that has to be done before yes that I'm
just pulling out a piece of the day time
yes so so so if you're going from higher
resolution time series to lower
resolution it can do some of that in
terms of I mean pandas is fantastic for
this you have a lot of control over how
you down sample in terms of taking means
or averages are 1st or like it I don't
think that's there right now so some of
the more sophisticated down sampling
type of things you would probably want
to do in pandas beforehand could you
just explain that and the code on cue
syntax okay is that query oh yes so they
leave the text before the colon is just
the name of the column in your data
frame the single letter after the colon
is the data type and there's four data
types that we support q4 quantitative so
just a number T for temporal so date
time and then oh and n for ordinal and
nominal which are ordered and unordered
categoricals now you can oftentimes
leave that colon data type out and we'll
infer it you typically the most common
place you have to add it is if for
example your date times or strings not a
date time or if you if we get it wrong
then it's an ordinal versus a nominal
things like that you sometimes you do
have to override it qua quantities
quantitative columns by pretty sure we
always get that right in this case I'm
just including it sort of
to be verbose and show how that works
yeah
yes and no so there's a to HTML method
that will export a static web page that
has the visualization and so you could
use it on any webpage it does not work
like if you want to use this at a
terminal based Python shell or something
like that what you would do in that case
is just save the JSON that we produce to
a file and then you'd need to install
node and NPM and the vagal light package
has a command-line tool that will
auto-generate SVG's or PNG s from that
json c so you can't do it it's not all
built into Altair it's sort of other
parts of the tool chain that that can do
that one last question son so what's
next for Altair is it depends on Vega
light or is this something else you want
to build onto out there yeah so the next
big set of changes are gonna come on the
interactive layer lands in Vega light
and we'll need to update the API is in
Altair the examples and I think we're
gonna spend a lot of time sort of
understanding how to spell out that
interactivity in a declarative manner
but also in a pythonic manner it I'm not
sure what that's going to look like the
other is that we and it's sort of on my
an ending slide we have all the
infrastructure to auto-generate ap is
that produce Vega light JSON it would
not be difficult to auto generate an R
API a scalar API and all the examples
and tests and it's not we're not
probably going to be the ones that do
those other languages but we have all
the code needed for that I do want to
mention so d3 Vega and Vega light come
out of the interactive data lab which is
Jeff here's group the University of
Washington and in particular Dominique
and Arvind or the sort of core deaths
Alan Vega and Vega light so many things
to them and they've been fantastic
collaborators on this okay let's thank
us - thank you